part of me dies inside whenever i go to
like a like a restaurant that does like
foreign
like european cuisine and i see [ __ ]
fish and chips there
i'm just like why are you selling fish
the best fish and chips though i ever
had was uh this british pop
british
something they should let you put the
vinegar on yourself yeah yeah right but
like there's places where they just like
do it for you it's [ __ ] up that's not
right yeah so like
the vinegar is like into in inside the
[ __ ] like
meat of the fish and i'm just like this
does not taste like fish it tastes like
vinegar yeah like as much as i love
vinegar don't get me wrong
what's the max from you to pay for fish
and chips abroad or in england that's
just a full stop
oh it's still silent i mean how big are
we talking like a normal portion like an
oil pool like that that's why i was like
you know
when i went to this place no that's the
most that's what i mean right you would
they charged me 22
i'm still angry about this by the way
they they're the same way 22
for a fish and chips 22 and it was mid
[ __ ] honestly it was not very was that
at the welsh place yeah was it the welsh
town
i'm sorry i feel like i'm like
completely ruining their like any
foreign tourism they get now but
that was like that that fish and chips
is a part and they increased the price
town reviewed by a welshman it was i
just i'm still annoyed about it
22 times 22 bucks are pretty ridiculous
my mom was
she probably slapped me if she saw that
i've had money for that it was it was
like a five pound fish and chips as well
it was not
my chip was it like a [ __ ] frozen
iceland fish and chips it wasn't good it
was it was like more batter than fish
ah that's that's that's what i've
noticed whenever whenever i've tried
tried fish and chips that have not been
from england of course even
even in england not every fish and chips
you get is [ __ ] good all that [ __ ] a
lot of them
like i'd say eighty percent of fish and
chips you get in england is [ __ ] anyway
why would i trust it outside of england
that's why you
a nice fancy kind of pub that does like
focuses on food a lot and they'll have
fish and chips on the menu it'll
probably be [ __ ] banging they might
have like
triple deep fried fries as well oh
honestly i want to take you guys to the
hobgoblin because
it's like a proper barramundi like
fishing i mean like the best fish and
chips i've had
is in brighton and it's like the one you
took us to
bankers i believe so i can't remember
probably
probably yeah they live next to a
[ __ ] ocean yeah
next to the [ __ ] sea right so that's
that's like it's good fish and chips
because the fish is just fresh and you
can taste this fresh and it's like yeah
the one you took us to in brian was
easily the best fish and chips i've ever
had but like
like even so like there's something
that's i feel weird when whenever like
you know you go to japan and people like
yo you can try the ramen
you can try the sushi you can try all
these different cuisines and
someone visits me in [ __ ] england and
i'm like yo you want to get so you know
what you want to get some fish and chips
go to the local chippy go to a pub and
i'm just like
that's what you're going wrong you
immediately have to get them drunk
so that they can't like so they don't
focus on like i can't judge yeah that's
what i do i'm like let's go to the pub
right away like
yeah yeah but four people's in you won't
kill each other but like
like the problem is when they stay
they're staying for like a week
right because you're just like how many
days in a row can they drink alcohol
before
they've realized i'm going to blow your
mind with a tesco meal
before before they realize that there's
just not much to our culture that we can
show off to like tourists that visit us
that's what i think i mean it's the same
problem in australia as well like
after you have a kangaroo steak there's
literally nothing else
it's like we have fish and chips as well
but like not as good
yeah because i i think the very the one
thing i've realized
after moving japan after moving outside
of england and you know living in places
like thailand and
japan and stuff like that is that um
there's
to me in england there's not much to do
apart from drink
right if you don't drink is that what
happens when you live in a place or is
that what happens when you like
like leave it and are aware like i
wonder do you think do you know what
there's much to do
like is there much to do in australia
that you know of other than going to the
pub and going to the beach not really
it's depressing at least we have really
nice [ __ ] beaches yeah at least
at least you've got that we don't even
have nice beaches like i am from
there my beach is very nice there's
plenty of free needles and
trash and everything like i i tell you i
tell people i'm from i like i grew up in
a beach town a beach city yeah it's
bright
bright and [ __ ] yeah we have pebble we
we like brighton is
the taurus beach in england right and
it's like the worst beach it's
pretty bad and i say that as someone who
grew up in brighton i'm born and bred in
bryce and i'm just like it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] rocks
you can't even go there barefooted right
and to make matters worse brighton is
just as expensive as london so like
what's the point of like
it didn't always it wasn't always like
that you're like i remember gentrified
my i
remember a time when bryson was cheap